good morning good morning prime minister
not going with those 20 fines that
they've necessarily broken the law what
do you think
well i think it's blindingly obvious to
everybody that the law has been broken
that these parties were going on a
number 10 downing street at a time that
you'll remember kay where other people
made huge sacrifices you know the
stories that we all hear and the
sacrifices that we all made of not
seeing loved ones not even being with
loved ones when they were in their last
days and hours and funerals not going
ahead huge sacrifices at a time when the
prime minister and those around him were
having parties why does it matter
anymore you know that was then it was
two years ago prime minister's getting
on with running the country and on the
world stage even the president of
ukraine has said that he's give he's
offered more support than any other
leader
it matters because it is a question of
integrity of telling the truth because
you'll remember as well that the prime
minister originally said the rules have
been obeyed at all times and then later
he said um well he knew nothing about it
and at times it's actually been at these
parties so it is an issue of integrity
and moral leadership on the issue of
russia and ukraine parliament stands as
one against russian aggression and in
defense of the ukrainian people whether
boris johnson is prime minister or
another a conservative mp that support
for ukraine and that opposition to what
russia is doing is resolute and is
steadfast uh on the issue of golden
visas of course it was brought in under
a previous labor government on balance
were they a bad idea
well it is clear that many of the people
have been sanctioned now actually came
in on golden visas and i think we want
to know
the
the truth behind how these people got
these uh visas what was known about them
and this system is clearly um not
working is not fit for a purpose i i
don't think anyone could have foreseen
back when golden visas were first
introduced what russia was going to do
in the future but clearly the system
does not work at all but there's much
greater reform that is needed here so
even now it's so difficult to tell who
really owns a yacht or a house
when i bought my house with a mortgage
you know it was in our name
and yet you've got these big mansions
and these yachts owned by shell
companies and it's not clear who the
beneficial owner is so as well as the
sanctions we need to clean up
russian money and laundered money in
london so we know the true owner of
properties yachts and bank accounts and
all the rest of it